[Music]
this year Britain's National Health
Service celebrates its 70th birthday
formed in 1948 it was the first state
health service in the world today the
modern NHS is almost unrecognizable from
the one that was created 70 years ago
it's the world's fifth biggest employer
with a budget of 110 billion pounds a
year but it's an urgent need of
treatment like many health care systems
the NHS is faced with a funding
shortfall and critical staff shortages
meaning its future looks perilous Lord
our adazi is one of the world's top
surgeons and a former British Health
Minister he's been on the health care
front line for three decades and he's
come up with a plan for reviving the NHS
these are my talking points the
government needs to transform the NHS
from a sickness serviced or health and
well-being service most of the chronic
disease is related to human behavior the
NHS spends almost nine billion pounds a
year dealing with diseases related to
smoking and the growing obesity epidemic
to cut costs the government needs to
tackle this public health crisis at its
root we do this in three way one
regulation banning smoking was a
wonderful example of that second
taxation introducing sugar tax or a levy
on alcohol thirdly Behavioral
Interventions how do we help people make
the right choices
we need to embrace innovation whether
that is digital which is transformed
every aspect of our life we need to do
the same in health the NHS is still
running on paper and fax we need to move
from that archaic times into the new
times of digital the NHS is the world's
largest purchaser of fax machines and in
some hospitals medical equipment is no
longer fit for purpose a recent report
found that machines from the 1980s was
still in use in NHS hospitals we need to
get commissioned the old stuff and saved
money to pay for the new innovations
robotics new drugs new interventions we
need to look at frugal innovations
technologies that are exceptionally
cheap but at the same time delivering as
good an outcome from a patient's
perspective in the 21st century data is
the energy or the fuel of transformation
anything you could measure you can
improve and data is one of the ways of
doing that 1 million people use the NHS
every 36 hours but there's no
centralized system where doctors can
access their medical data most patients
seeing me expects me to have all the
data from their general practice we need
to drive this integration between
primary care hospital and back into the
community you can actually predict
disease before you see the manifestation
of disease by segmenting the population
and identifying those at greater risk to
do this the NHS will have to tackle
fears over personal data being shared
sharing data is critical from a
patient's perspective and we need to win
the confidence of the public when it
comes to the privacy and security aspect
of data sharing
[Music]
the NHS is facing a funding gap by 2020
it's estimated to be 20 billion pounds
short a lot of people out there think
investing in health care is an a
bottomless pit
I could confidently tell you not just my
work look at the work The Lancet
Commission the world Innovation Summit
for health care the best return on
investment any country could make is in
health healthy nation means a productive
nation healthy nation means economic
growth for every pound you spend in
health you get two pounds back quality
should be the organizing principle of
any Health System it's a wonderful
future if we embrace it
[Music]